what was the Genesis of the project for
you James
I had finished the previous film that I
did I really didn't know what I was
going to do and my brother had found
it's like a it sounds like a TV movie
that I would have watched when I was a
kid on Hallmark Hall of Fame we found
this big chest
filled with photographs and paperwork
from Ellis Island and then you know we
found out our name which was grazerstein
and all this stuff and I thought well I
don't know any of this
and I started to remember my grandfather
and my grandmother
I got a little angry at myself because
they spoke virtually no English they
spoke Yiddish to each other even to the
end and my mother would say you know go
listen to your grandmother and your
grandfather listen to their stories
please and I didn't like them very much
because I was a 13 year old 12 year old
whatever jerk and I thought the Clash
were cool and Adam Mohawk and all this
crap and I didn't want to hear about
Russia
and what I do remember though and this
is a I don't get out very much you'll
notice in the course of this
conversation but one of the things I did
notice was that it was quite the
opposite of
I came to America it was fantastic I
loved it I made a billion dollar no what
happened was they were dislocated it's
all in the movie by the way uh my
grandmother saw her parents get their
heads chopped off by uh by uh Cossacks
the uh my the you know not knowing how
to eat the banana and looking at the
spaghetti like it was Bloody worms and
you know the with the monologue that
Marion Courtyard has in the church where
she says that we're all together like
animals on the ship and all that was
taken directly from my grandparents and
then I started of course asking my
father all these questions and the sort
the story started to build from there
and I took as much of the family history
and put it into the film as I could on
my mother's side uh her parents had a
restaurant on the Lower East Side it was
called hurwitz's
I'm going to give you one guess of the
family name by the way uh no it was
hurwitz and so obviously and so uh they
my great aunt died only about a year ago
she was 101 years old and quite loose it
up until the end and she talked about a
guy named Max hoxton who was uh the
local pimp who recruited women out of
Ellis Island because you couldn't have
solo women coming to the country so he
would pick these women out and bring
them in and she described him as a kind
of she said he was alone a loony was she
basically said he was a Mercurial guy
and and he you know fake proper like yes
I'll be seated in this kind of thing but
in fact he was
kind of a psychopath and he used to go
eat at hurwitz's so he would bring his
women in and all that and I thought well
that sounds like a great part for Mr
Phoenix you know who's I like to torture
uh and um he was in agony the whole time
so everything I'm saying is a lie to her
I said that's right he said why you do
this to me it was terrible
uh one of the beautiful things about the
film I really think is how it does not
paint Bruno why so as a villain in fact
it seems like you know obviously he is
the villain but in order for her for Ava
to have sympathy for him to feel what
she feels for him by the end of the film
he cannot be so black and white it has
to be a level there has to be gradations
there you see him trying to survive you
see him trying to essentially make his
own living in in America as well how how
much of a of a line did you as a as a
writer want to cross there and kind of
making him a little bit yeah a little
bit more gray
I don't really have much use for a film
where the characters are looked down
upon as garbage by the filmmakers or the
actor frankly when the actor I sense
that the actor is even playing a part in
sort of condescending to the character
and in a sense the movie is a lie in
that small way because he in real life
he would have just you know sold
probably sold throughout to the cops
instantly
so
but I didn't want the film to be about
that I wanted the film to be about the
opposite of that which was the potential
for redemption in a person no matter how
loathsome they may be I read something
not to get too sententious but I read a
great quote Once by uh the writer George
Eliot and she said uh the purpose of art
if I use that dirty word forgive me is
to extend our sympathies which I thought
was really beautiful and I had been up
late one night Turner Classic Movies was
playing lestrada
and uh I just found that the core of
that film was intensely beautiful
because
what Fellini found was that no matter
how loathsome zampano was in the end you
have to love him obviously speak about
Joaquin uh do you guys I mean as we said
this is your fourth collaboration with
him have things changed since your first
ones yeah I mean it was what 299 was The
Yards that's right the first time we
worked together
he had done really virtually nothing nor
had I for that matter
which meant that I could sort of Boss
him around
the power Dynamic has changed a lot
which I don't really like
but he he was in back then he was I
think he was like you know four years
old or whatever and and and he would be
fantastic and take one line reading
three would be great and take seven line
reading two would be great and take not
you'd have to piece it together he was
like lightning in a bottle you could see
that he had a brilliant capacity for
acting but it wasn't there wasn't a
craft yet
by the time I made two lovers which was
the film I made before this one
um he was a completely different animal
and he had a a method not the method but
he had a method about how he would work
to the point where
he would usually tell me to shut up
and I would say to him I'd say Joaquin
would do another take I said Joaquin
he'd go I know
the other favorite thing that he likes
to say is eight
so if I say to him Joaquin on that last
take he goes eight now that I didn't
know what that meant for like two months
then finally I asked him so what are you
doing eight what does that mean he means
it means I've been acting since I'm
eight you don't have to tell me
I also love the the feel for the 1920s
Lower East Side performance world the
sort of sub-sub Vaudeville sensibility
that that to me seemed to to evoke
um obviously not only that world but
also the very thin line between sort of
performance and prostitution and where
those where that was and also you can
almost sort of see the beginnings uh or
or maybe perhaps in the in the midst of
it uh you know the sort of the Seedy
underbelly of New York City Life that
theater is all based on a real theater
called the Haymarket which I had read
about and there's a great book by the
way by a guy named Luke Sant written in
which describes all of this and rather
fabulous detail a guy is basically a
genius
but the the the there's this theater was
you're quite right it was sub-vardville
you know and I Joaquin and I really
struggled with it because in essence he
has to give a kind of
bad performance
like on purpose you know because it was
bad the show was almost assuredly
terrible and and by the way considerably
more racist than is portrayed in the
movie they would come out in blackface
and do a whole thing and
we tried it I never shot it because it
was really offensive and it was even
though it was accurate it totally took
you out of the movie and all of that
stuff though the rest of it which was
you know women of the world walking into
the audience and sort of parading around
that was taken from all the stuff I read
about the Haymarket and and that
tradition was killed off pretty much by
the by by films
all of your films in New York right is
that I I am guilty as charred I love
making films here I think it's an
amazing place and people say to me I was
in London doing something and which
which was the commercial and and they
said we're making a movie here is much
better you know it's London it's great
I'm like no it's much worse and in New
York isn't it bad like people are
constantly walking through like the set
and everything
I'm like no I just had to get in a car
and drive like an hour and a half to
come to shepparton where I ate the worst
sandwich I've ate in my life
you know New York I'm on Arthur Avenue
uh if I don't like the crew lunch I'm
walking and having uh fresh mozzarella
it's fantastic New York's great what are
you talking about